مساء الخير في سؤال بيتباع الى ذهن ناس
كتيره يعني طبعا ده بعيدا عن السياسه اللي
احنا متعودين نتكلم فيها لكن سؤال بيهم
ناس كتيره ليه شخص معين لما بيجي يختار
شريك الحياه بيختاره بشكل معين او نسال
السؤال بشكل تاني ليه بتنجز الى الانسانه
دي دون غيرها وليه الانسانه دي بتنجب
للانسان ده وبملامح وبشكله وليس بانسان
اخر ليه لما يكون في اربع خمس رجاله
قاعدين وتمر عليهم سيده واحد يعتبرها ملكه
جمال فيما يعتبرها اخرين ان هي او يديروا
ظهرهم ليها والعكس بالنسبه للسيدات السؤال
ده مرتبط بان احنا نفهم تعبير مهم جدا
اسمه لاف ماب او خريطه الحب هل في خريطه
للحب العلم بيقول اه
واول واحد يتكلم عن هذه الخريطه عالم
امريكي اسمه جون ماني وجون ماني ده بدا
يتكلم على فكره خريطه الحب من
الثمانينات ويه كتابات مختلفه غيره خد هذه
الكتابات وطورها في اشكال مختلفه كتاب
اسمه انام او لاف سينس اف لاف حاجات كتيره
انما الفكره الاساسيه اللي عملها جون ماني
فكرتها تستحق ان احنا نقف عندها ونفهمها
عشان نفهم ازاي احنا او ليه احنا بيبقى
عندنا او عشان نفهم مشاعرنا تجاه الجنس
الاخر الحقيقه انه خريطه الحب فكرتها
بسيطه ان الانسان لما بيتولد بيتولد صفحه
بيضا ما عندوش اي تفضيلات تجاه الجنس
الاخر ولكن
بيبتدي كون ملامح يعني بلو برنت او و
خريطه كده او يعني دليل استرشادي بالحاجات
اللي بيحبها وبترتب بالسعاده عنده من
اليوم الاول لميلاده يعني على سبيل المثال
لما بيتولد الولد او البنت
فالبنت بتبقى بتحب باباها بتحب خالها بتحب
جارها مش بتحبه بمعنى يعني لكن هي بتبقى
تشعر بالسعاده مع باباها ف بترتبط بلحظات
السعاده لما بتكون في حضوره وابوها ليه
ملامح معينه صوته اذا كان ضعيف ولا اذا
كان اجش طبيل رفيع عنده شعر اصلع اسمر
ابيض كل دي بترتبط عندها بلحظات رضا من
هذا الاب اللي هو حنون عليها وبيحبها من
خالها من صديق باباها الى اخره وبتطور
المساله طوال الحياه مع المدرس مع الجار
مع الاخ مع كذا الملامح اللي هي بتشعر
بالارتياح فيها منذ لحظات الاولى للميلاد
وبت وبتفضل تتطور لغايه وقت البلوغ
والتحول الى رجل او الى بنت جون ماني
بيقول انه خريطه الحب دي او الملامح دي
اللي ما بيتولد بيها ده راي جون ماني في
ناس لهم راي اخر بتعامله زي اللغه اللغه
القوميه النيتف لانجوج او الماذر تانج
اللغه الام بتتكون ببطء ولكن لما تكون على
مدار سنوات بتبقى متاصله جدا في الذهن
يعني اللي دارس لغه زي حالاتي يبقى عارف
انه اللغه دي بتبقى يعني انت بتتعلمها ف
يعني وانت صغير وبعدين بتثبت تماما في
يعني عقلك بحيث ان حتى اي لغه ثانيه
بتتعلمها كل ما بيتاخر الوقت بجد تعلم
فيه تاجد صعوبه في تعلم لغه اجنبيه اخرى
وزي اللهجه او زي الاكسنت انت بتكتسب
والمفردات انت انت بتكتسب مفردات الشخص ده
غير مفردات الشخص ده استقبالك لدلاله
الكلام ا غير مش بالضبط زي نفس الشخص اللي
هو بيتكلم نفس لغتك يعني على سبيل المثال
انت ممكن زي يعني واحد لما تقول له يا
حبيبي ينزعج جدا لان كلمه حبيبي تنطبق
عنده او بترتبط في زنه بانها استخفاف او
بانها يعني كلمه او الراجل ده راجل طيب
يبقى معناها بين قوسين راجل اهبل الكلمات
ليها دلالات بتختلف من شخص اخر وكذلك
خريطه الحب الملامح اللي انت بتحبها في
الجنس
الاخر السيده الرجل او السيده يعني بتبقى
شديده الخصوصيه وبترتب بتجارب كثيره
ومتداخله وتفاصيل من لحظه الميلاد الاخرى
وتكتمل مع البلوغ وبعدها تقريبا من الصعب
جدا جدا ان تتغير بمجرد وصولك الى مرحله
البلوغ من غير انت انت ما يكون عندك وعي
بانت بتحب ايه انت بتجد لما بتحين لحظه
الاختيار او لحظه بتحين في السن المناسب
الى النظر الى الجنس الاخر باهتمام بتجد
نفسك بتروح الى ملامح معينه ما انتش عارف
ليه لكن ده سببها ان هي خريطه تكونت على
مقار سن ده راي جون ماني وبيف السر لنا
ليه بنحب حد وليه ما بنحبش حد ليه بعتبر
شخص جميل و واحد تاني بيعتبره انه مش جميل
او مش وسيم زي المثل الانجليزي ما بيقول و
مانز ميت از و مانز بويزن يعني اللي لحم
الحد سم الحد تاني وزي ما بيقولوا في
العربي يعني لولا اختلاف الاذواق لبره
السلع في ناس لهم راي ثاني شايفين ان
المساله مش بس مكتسبه من البيئه ولكن كمان
بتيجي فيها جزء جيني يعني مولود في جيناته
انه يميل الى شخص معين طيب هل موجود في
جيناتي ان انا اميل الى شخص اسمر او شخص
ابيض هم بيتكلموا في قضيه اكثر خطوره لانه
بيعتقد ان احيانا بيكون نتيجه الجينات مش
ان انا بفضل شكل معين لا ده اكت من كده ان
ممكن يكون النتيجه ان شخص يميل زي
الغالبيه العظمى من البشر الى الجنس الاخر
او يميل الى نفس الجنس وهو ده تفسيرهم الى
الشذوذ الجنسي اللي ليه تفسير ليه بينما
جون ماني له تفسير اخر ان حتى الاشخاص
اللي عندهم شذوذ جنسي ناتج من خريطه الحب
اللي تشكلت منذ لحظات الميلاد فيما انه
الاخرين اللي بيعتقدوا ان المساله ليها
بعد جيني وانها مولوده بالجينات انه
بيقولوا ان الاخرين اللي هم عندهم يعني م
الجنس الاخر بيفسر بانه هو انه ليس اختيار
ولكنه يعني ا يعني يعني مولود بدي قضيه
خلافيه ممكن نخصص لها حلقه اخرى اذا كانت
محل اهتمام حضراتكم اشكركم والى لقاء اخر
ان شاء
الله